[Musique]
et cet invité aujourd'hui c'est vous
germain louve et bonjour bonjour et
bienvenue sur ce plateau vous êtes
danseur étoile à l'opéra de paris et
vous signer des choses qui se danse qui
vient de sortir chez fayard un texte
singulier dans un milieu qui l'est tout
autant vous danserez la bayadère dans
quelques semaines à l'opéra bastille ici
à paris c'est l'un des grands ballets du
répertoire classique c'est une revanche
parce que ce spectacle que vous avez
répété pendant des mois il ya presque
deux ans vous n'avez pas pu jouer à
cause de la pandémie oui exactement là
on l'a répété pour le jouer en décembre
et quelques jours avant la première là
il y avait une décision gouvernementale
pour continuer la fermeture de théâtre
et donc on va malheureusement la jouer à
guichets fermés ce n'est pas très
agréable
voilà vous l'avais joué sans public est
ce que l'épidémie avec son lot de gestes
barrières de distanciation physique et
toutes ces belles expressions à a changé
quelque chose dans la façon de danser
dans le rapport au corps oui je pense
que déjà aujourd'hui il ya vraiment un
réel plaisir et une l'engouement une
envie à la fois pour nos danseurs et
artistes et pour le public je pense de
retourner dans les théâtres et de
retourner sur scène donc déjà c'est pas
quelque chose qui a changé mais ça a
rappelé aussi notre passion et notre
conviction et puis évidemment ça a
changé le rapport par exemple tout
simple mais aujourd'hui on fait très
attention à notre bouteille d'eau à se
désinfecter les mains avant la
répétition vous vous imaginez bien qu'il
ya des rôles comme roméo et juliette
justement qu'on voit à l'écran qui
implique des baisers qui implique de
transpirer et donc de mettre un peu en
danger au niveau sanitaire l'autre donc
voilà plus de plus de précautions vous
avez été nommé étoile jamin louve et un
soir vous dansiez le rôle de siegfried
dans le lac des sims t il ya un peu plus
de 5 en décembre 2016 vous aviez 24 ans
vous dites dans ce livre dans ce livre
que depuis tout petit ce que vous dansez
c'est le cri qu'à l'intérieur de vous
oui je pense que c'est vraiment la danse
pour moi c'était pas du tout une
ambition de carrière c'était vraiment
une pulsion une pulsion que j'appelle
vital parce que c'était quelque chose de
vraiment inhérents au reste une manière
pour moi de m'exprimer à un moment de
l'enfance où j'avais peut-être pas
encore les mots pour pouvoir tout dire
et je pense que j'appelle ça un cri
parce que il ya toujours eu une énergie
et une volonté débordante de toucher en
fait le monde qui m'entoure et les
autres avec les moyens qui m'était
donnée à savoir mon corps et le
mouvement elle est très belle 7,7 que
vous racontez vous êtes tout petit vous
mettez la musique à fond et là vous
sentez quelque chose près ce qui est
plus fort que vous quoi ce livre et
c'est le récit de votre parcours de la
bourgogne où vous êtes né aux dorures de
l'opéra le récit évidemment d'années de
travailler et d'exigence mais c'est
surtout une réflexion sur la façon dont
vous tentez vous de concilier qui vous
êtes un jeune homme de 28 ans danseur
étoile homosexuels publiquement engagé à
gauche est ce que le monde de la danse
classique véhicule comme conservatisme
monde on vous dit même parfois qu'il
vous fait honte oui il m'arrive de me
poser vraiment des questions sur ce
qu'on représente ce qu'on incarne la
manière dont la manière pédagogique dont
on apprend la danse classique et avec
laquelle on véhicule les images
sur cette pratique quand je dis que j'ai
honte c'est vraiment sûr sur des
endroits très précis et et heureusement
anecdotique mais je pense que c'est
important de toujours réfléchir pour
plus d'1 clusaz ion pour pour imaginer
que la danse s'adresse à tout le monde
et la danse s'adresse du monde en tant
que spectacle mais aussi en tant que
pratique moi la danse classique quand
j'ai commencé c'était quelque chose déjà
de très étonnant j'étais un jeune garçon
dans un milieu rural les gens
comprenaient pas trop autour de moi mes
parents qui étaient très ouverts ils
m'ont toujours soutenu dans cette
direction heureusement mais mais voilà
j'ai aussi subi ce que c'était que les
clichés par rapport à ce milieu et donc
je trouve ça très important oui de
pouvoir continuer la réflexion sur
comment comment représente la danse
classique comment représentent ces
ballets qui sont vieux de plus de 150
ans ces rôles qui peuvent paraître
parfois désuet comment les incarnent
aujourd'hui vous dites vous écrivez vous
avez parfois l'impression d'interpréter
des rôles en totale inadéquation avec ce
que vous êtes on parlait de la bayadère
tout à l'air qui dépeint pour ceux qui
ne le connaissent pas à une vision assez
anachronique dites-vous irréaliste de
l'inde aux relents assez parfois
racistes ouais vous le savez pas ce que
la première fois que vous avez dansé à
bastille vous était très jeune à l'opéra
vous avez dansé dans ce qu'on appelle la
danse dite des qui a été
rebaptisé depuis par benjamin millepied
ça avait fait beaucoup parler on
pourrait parler de don quichotte que
vous avez dansé cet hiver là aussi c'est
un rôle avec une représentation de
l'homme très machiste bien ancrés dans
le sol comment est-ce qu'on compose avec
ça alors justement voilà la question en
effet c'est ses rôles qui sont des
structures qui sont qui sont des rôles
qui ont été interprétés de différentes
manières depuis depuis des décennies
comment après en effet on se les
réapproprie quand on se sent pas
forcément en accord avec la personnalité
que d'autres ont pu employer et moi
c'est toute ma passion et et tout mon
plaisir c'est justement de d'arriver à
travers cette histoire et à travers ses
narrations à travers ces personnalités
d'arriver à utiliser mes propres
expériences d'utiliser qui je suis mais
aussi qui je vois autour de moi et qui
j'ai envie de voir qui j'ai envie d'être
à travers ses rôles même dans la
bayadère qui est le rôle de ceux-là qui
est un guerrier noble très puissant en
haut de la hiérarchie des castes de
l'endroit où il est un guerrier est en
fait il ya des moyens bien sûr c'est
aussi ça ma réflexion c'est de poser les
problèmes et de montrer et de trouver
les moyens pour moi de naviguer dans ces
dans ces zones voilà qui sont pas
toujours évidentes dans sexe que vous
êtes et ce en quoi vous croyez et puis
les choses avancent aussi un sur la
question de la représenter la diversité
dans le corps de ballet on avance sur
l'art et l'écriture à la marge de
certains classiques nous parler de la la
bayadère la danse contemporaine bien sûr
qui est très en avance oui il ya
vraiment des choses qui sont faites on a
une direction
alexander nef directeur général aurélie
dupont directrice du ballet qui sont
très enclin est motivé pour que pour que
les choses évoluent et les choses
avancent il ya eu un manifeste de la
diversité qui a été écrit
juste avant le confinement il ya deux
ans par des danseurs noirs de la
compagnie pour parler justement des
points qui peuvent être améliorées et
pour parler de ces questions de la
représentation de ce qu'on amène sur
scène de comment on résout ces problèmes
de représentation de la diversité et
donc il ya beaucoup de choses qui ont
été tout de suite saisi pour pour
avancer en ce sens ce discours qui est
le vôtre assumer aussi vous avez été en
première ligne pendant la grève à
l'opéra une grève historique sur la
question des retraites
est ce qu'elle ne vous jamais de tour
d'autant qu'on peut dire que vous êtes
un pur produit du système
que vous critiquez ajustable
oui oui c'est justement parce que je
suis un pur produit du système et même
en annonçant plus loin du système
culturel français ayant été élève au
conservatoire à rayonnement régional de
chalon sur saône puis à l'école de danse
de l'opéra de paris aujourd'hui au
ballet national de l'opéra à paris donc
j'ai toujours j'ai appris la danse à
travers les moyens publics qui m'ont été
donnés donc au contraire c'est justement
parce que je tiens énormément à ce
système que je voudrais le conserver je
voudrais qu'ils puissent évoluer dans le
bon sens et c'est vrai que la réforme
des retraites c'était un moment où nous
danseurs nous nous sentions vitrines et
nous nous sentions
l'exemple parfait de qu'est ce que c'est
qu'un régime spécial avec des
spécificités très particulière qui nous
empêche évidemment d'aller jusqu'à 62 67
ans dans notre métier aujourd'hui un
danseur qui s'opèrent à 42 ans
d'ailleurs vous parler à juste titre de
la schizophrénie que vous vivez en
permanence qui voudrait à la fois que
vous rentriez dans un moule très
exigeant voilà vous raconter des moments
désagréables si vous avez eu à l'opéra
tout en faisant exploser semoule et vous
rappeler que les plus grands danseurs de
nour est fanny jean ski plus près marie
agnès gillot c'était des danseurs des
artistes extrêmement libre oui c'est des
artistes qui justement ont irradié la
scène à travers le monde par leur
liberté par leur singularité et je pense
que c'est des vrais exemples et des
idéaux pour nous à suivre et à
poursuivre donc en effet je pense que
cette liberté elle est primordiale et
elle me tient énormément à coeur c'est
un manifeste ce récit pour démocratiser
la danse vous l'écriviez vous le disiez
tout à l'heure et son public aujourd'hui
plutôt constituée de pau parfumé souvent
rider les apprécieront comment on fait
pour démocratiser la danse et moi je
pense moi il ya déjà des choses qui sont
heureusement mise en place je pense que
moi aujourd'hui j'ai l'impression que ce
qui permettrait de d'ouvrir encore plus
la danse et l'image de la danse ce
serait de sortir de nos théâtres je
pense que un théâtre c'est un lieu à la
fois magique magnifique et magique
pardon plein de mystères plein de beauté
mais c'est aussi un lieu parfois
excluant j'ai beaucoup de gens dans mon
entourage qui qui ont l'impression de ne
pas être à leur place en allant dans un
théâtre notamment un théâtre comme
l'opéra garnier qui est très imposant
qui qui est très sur l'avenue de l'opéra
impressionnant je veux avoir les moyens
même s'il ya des
et pour les jeunes ça reste très cher
d'aller bien sûr moi c'est plus alors
les évidemment qu'il faut avoir les
moyens mais moi je vais plus loin
puisque aujourd'hui en effet il ya des
systèmes qui sont mis en place c'est
vraiment que sans même parler d'argent
il ya des gens qui sont pas légitimes de
franchir les portes d'un théâtre mais
même d'un théâtre en région et à jeu
j'ai déjà vu que qu'en fait on retrouve
un peu le même public partout et voilà
je pense que c'est important aujourd'hui
d'imaginer comment les danseurs les
troupes les artistes on peut se déplacer
sortir de théâtre ce qui était le cas
finalement dans la danse des signes sur
le parvis de l'opéra pendant la réforme
des retraites image qui a énormément
marqué les touchés parce que les
danseuses volontairement sont sortis de
leur écrin ya être légitime est allé
voir à se retrouver dans un endroit
pareil à un être légitime à danser dans
un endroit pareil il y a beaucoup de
comment dire de personnes qui se disent
non moi je vous disais vous venez pas du
tout d'un d'un milieu qui vous pouvez
vous amener vers la danse c'est le cas
de beaucoup de jeunes qui se disent non
je n'ai pas ma place quoi vous parlez
d'une petite fille dont la maman c'est
terrible petite fille qui a la peau
noire qu'on oriente vers le hip hop et
qui dit d'elle-même qu'elle a
l'impression d'être une tâche c'était
terrible ces mots moi c'est justement ça
que j'ai envie de combattre et et
justement ça fait partie des anecdotes
qui me font honte et quand j'entends ça
je me dis étant moi même en plus blancs
et étant un peu physiquement la figure
même de de ce qu'on attend un peu d'un
danseur classique c'est pour ça que ça
me semble important parallèlement à ma
pratique de pouvoir réfléchir et parler
librement de comment on peut permettre à
ce genre de choses de ne pas arriver il
danse assez résister c'est la conclusion
de votre livre tout à fait c'est pas moi
qui le dit ce n'est pas merci beaucoup
merci germain louvain date revenu ce
matin sur le plateau de paris direct
c'est un très beau texte oui les
questions vous l'avez compris de danse
mais pas que des choses qui se danse
dont qui sort chez fayard je montre pas
mon exemplaire parce qu'il est c'est un
exemplaire
mais vous le trouverez on les voit là
bien sûr il sorti en librairie
hier exactement merci beaucoup cette
journée on se retrouve juste après la
pause